For many of the million and a half Catholics
in the United Arab Emirates it's the stuff
of dreams.
The idea of the Pope visiting Arabian Peninsula,
the birthplace of Islam, was unthinkable a
few years ago.
Pope Francis was invited by Abu Dhabi's rulers.
Local Parish Priest Rheinhold Sahner says
the Pontiff wants to foster tolerance and
promote a moderate brand of Islam.
It's definitely a signal that he wants to
build bridges.
He wants to say, look, Islam is changing,
it can change and also wants to change.
The Emirates have declared 2019 as the year
of tolerance - and there is a lot of symbolism
in the invitation.
I am sure it will enhance the relationship
between different religions, it is a historic
visit.
Pope Francis will be in the Emirates for three
days.
He's expected to address a series of issues
including the lack of legal rights for foreign
workers.
But the fact a Pope will lead a Catholic service
on the Islamic Arabian
Peninsula
is
a
sensation
in itself.